and finally good news starting to get
warmer in this country I'm excited about
that it's getting warmer that's right
the the polar vortex that's what they're
calling it mm-hmm the polar vortex that
put the entire country into a deep
freeze is now headed up north to Canada
[Applause]
finally some payback for giving us
Justin Bieber
[Applause]
they are an angry mob I hate that guy
very historic times were in for the past
week now I think it's been seven days
Colorado has been allowing the sale of
legal recreational marijuana can a
related story in one week the population
of Colorado has jumped to 315 million
people all quite happy and none of them
in a big hurry
all entering - dude - he eats one now
everyone's fine I will preface this joke
by saying everyone's fine but honey Boo
Boo's family was involved in a minor
traffic accident yeah yeah parently
their home rear-ended their neighbors
home
[Laughter]
interesting I just heard this guy go
that was a good one I can hear you
you're here he thinks he's watching this
on television
that's a good one
[Applause]
Heys head looks weird in person this is
weird McDonald's restaurants in Japan
have started selling cheese fries that
you can't get here in the United States
yeah which makes me wonder who really
won world war two those cheese fries
because if there's anything the Japanese
are known for its cheese that guys quiet
use a bathroom this is exciting news
this week is Nicolas Cage's 50th
birthday
yeah cages friends handed in a birthday
card and without reading at cage
immediately said okay I'll be in the
movie I'll do it the National Society of
Film Critics has named the Coen brothers
new movie inside Llewyn Davis the best
film of the year yeah
they also also named duke lee film with
the best soon to be porn title
the government is accusing the makers of
several weight loss products of
deceiving the public yeah probably the
most deceptive of these companies
Cinnabon I thought I would you shed
weight apprise the Cinnabon workout it
yeah where it's fantastic